[Music]
of somalia once before now he's back in
office again
my country needs to work forward and not
go backward and it doesn't need violence
and revenge whatever was done to people
we call for forgiveness
this time the gunfire on the streets of
the capital mogadishu is in celebration
rather than armed conflict
people here are glad to have a change of
leader
hassan sheikh defeated outgoing
president muhammad abdullahi mohammad
known as farmageo whose popularity has
declined over his five years in office
his critics say he's made somalia's
conflicts and economy worse and that he
tried to stay in power by stalling the
election
it was meant to happen more than a year
ago somalis don't actually get to vote
mps were chosen by officials and clan
representatives then the mps voted for
presidential candidates in a series of
three rounds it's an electoral system
that was introduced after somalia's
central government collapsed in 1991
it's been much criticized it was meant
to be transitional so that somalia could
move to having elections with one person
one vote that hasn't happened the one
thing that this system has always
delivered is a change
of ahead of state
everyone familiar with the process says
buying of votes and corruption are
widespread but loyalties aren't
guaranteed
in the last round it was the opposition
uniting against outgoing president
farmagio that tipped the balance
but hassan sheikh inherits some major
challenges
the armed group al-shabab is stronger
than it was when his first term ended
five years ago
it controls swathes of the countryside
and somali has been suffering one of its
worst droughts in decades
the un has warned of a pending famine
more than 700 000 people have lost their
farms and livestock and fled the
countryside into camps
they urgently need help
but in mogadishu it's a moment for
optimism
we celebrate the victory of president
hassan sheikh mohammed we want him to
prioritize security and establish one
person one vote and create jobs
especially for the youth
the extended election period has been
tense and sometimes violent
now it's over people hope things will
get better malcolm webb al jazeera
mogadishu somalia